[Music]
i'm lauren zima we are here at the
Beverly Hilton at the 25th annual race
to erase MS gala it's such an amazing
cause and Lance Bass supports this cause
every year but he's also marking another
anniversary the 20th anniversary of
insane it's gonna be May I don't want to
shock you but I got to ask you about
this and sync pop-up shop situation what
made you guys want to do that and I know
you said you'll be there will we see the
other guys oh of course I mean it's we
wanted to do something special for the
fans you know the fans are who gave us
the star they're the ones who you know
wrote the people and raised the money
and I mean that's it's all for them so
this is really just to honor them so we
wanted to do something a little more
special than just showing up at the
ceremony so we've created a nice in sync
experience the dirty pop-up we're
building it now so I have no idea what
it's going to look like but it'll be
really fun installation pieces that you
can have a lot of great Instagram
pictures with we got an Instagram will
we see the other guys there too of
course yeah we're I mean we'll be around
it's gonna be open for a few days so
you'll see a few of us popping up pretty
much every day popping up well with the
Walk of Fame everybody's so excited for
because we haven't seen you guys all
together in a moment is everybody gonna
be at that ceremony everyone will be
there oh yeah I mean we don't do
anything in secret unless it's all five
which is very rare these days the last
time we were all five together was JC's
40th birthday which is a couple of years
ago it's really hard to get us all five
on tour like are you guys getting a
little busy oh yeah we're excited I mean
we planned this whole ceremony around
his tour coming to LA yeah it's gonna be
a nice fun weekend all right so T's
something that's in store for the
ceremony well actually uh Ellen will be
talking and presenting it to us along
with Carson Daly which i think is just
so us you know with Ellen everything she
represents and Carson's starting out
with us on TRL it's the perfect two
people to really help us be abducted
what you guys are talking about that
with each other how does it feel like
you're getting a star on the Walk of
Fame it's the 20th anniversary I mean
it's it's silly really I mean I mean we
talked pretty much daily
so we're always kind of just joking
around so this is just one of those
weird events that are like really like
how do we get here this is so weird
our whole career we felt like we didn't
deserve anything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]